how long have I been since you'd
actually played together I'm not sure
exactly
last time we actually played together
was our last show
yeah which is outside lands in San
Francisco in August of 2015
Wow so that was like three over three
years mm-hmm
yeah that's a long time yeah yeah it is
a long time we need but I mean we've
been playing together for about 15 years
straight yeah before that three years so
yeah that's a long time
that's the we're quite busy in the in
the three to four years you were working
together yeah no I was taking a break
wasn't cause I mean we were sick of
playing music it's just we wanted to
make more music I guess
want to be home feel what it's like to
kind of settle in a little bit mm-hmm
cuz we hadn't done that I mean we lived
in Nashville for six years or something
like that and had never really spent any
time here mm-hmm so it was time for that
I think that part of the reason was the
break I mean the break even though was
three years it doesn't feel like it was
that long it doesn't it it doesn't
because we were traveling so much that
the first year I spent the first years
trying to get my life in order like
taking I get told what I even wear what
you know what I even wanted yeah where
did I mean when you talked I think I
read an interview somewhere you talked
about feeling like you need to sort of
recalculate your life sort of at the
peak of things that enjoying they turn
blue tours just like what do I do now is
like oh yeah well we're gonna take Danny
getting a break he's gonna do the arcs I
assumed he'd do a solo record and I just
like I just funding I think ultimately
we both we mail both made it quite a few
records but it you know the terrain on
his end was a lot less that I I went on
towards my wife for summer but most then
we spent at home and the reason why
doesn't feel like that long a period of
times because it was the first time in
my adult life like after the age of 21
Russ consistent
for months able to wake up in the same
bed yeah it was very that a novelty that
has not worn off